in this video we're going to talk about  indexing erase how do you access a  certain piece of information inside of  an array this array their pet names you  can tell is an array because of the  square brackets is a list of pet names  that either I own or my friends own if  we want to return wookie okay that we  would count we would say okay one two  three four five six you think if you did  but that's actually not how it works it  starts at zero so we said pet names zero  like this that would return Maurice if  we try to do pet names one that would  return Hermione so it's really important  did you just remember to start counting  at zero or else your information that  you get back isn't going to be what you  expect so if we did want to see Wilke  two three four five if we had something  like return pet names five that would go  to look